in the aftermath residents of the
coastal town of teknaf in Bangladesh
returned to salvage what is left of
their homes
Rescuers and volunteers worked through
the night to clear uprooted trees and
debris strewn across
a cyclone mocha slammed into the region
with the ferocity unseen in recent times
satellite pictures show its Fierce eye
over the region thanks to Allah because
there was a worry the Cyclone would be
very big but it had less impact this
could have been worse even then many
houses got damaged people have no money
and nothing to eat many of their
belongings got damaged
season and
its part live more than 3 million people
the vulnerable evacuated to shelters
Holmes land vegetation infrastructure
nothing spared as it made its way Inland
rooftops ripped off and trees uprooted
by its savagery when starting 130 miles
an hour brought three meter Storm surges
that inundated low-lying towns and
cities
its effects have been felt on the
world's largest refugee camp where a
million rohingyas fled persecution by
the Myanmar military
their flimsy homes made from mud bamboo
and tarpaulin offer little protection
but miraculously they have been largely
spared
it's across the border in Myanmar that
Aid agencies are most concerned with the
ongoing conflict between ethnic
minorities and the military access to
these vulnerable areas is hard to get we
estimate that about
million people in this effect
that were already in humanitarian need
even before this cyclone and the Damage
that has been caused is only going to
make that worse
misery heaped once again on those
endured Decades of conflict poverty and
uncertainty Neville Lazarus Sky News